[Music]
larry is on the line
larry is in omaha hi larry welcome to
the dave ramsey show i'm a little short
on time go straight to your question
sure dave thank you and john for taking
my call sure
we personally are set i'm 73 my wife is
70.
i've been following your principles
before i even knew you so we are
financially set my question is about my
son
he is going to lose his house he is
totally
financially incompetent we have tried to
talk to him by example by words
he and his wife are of this set that we
have to have separate finances
she will not get on board with him
refinancing the house she doesn't want
her name on anything he does
uh so they're going to foreclose the
house my question is
i've i can buy the house outright they
only got 55 000 left on the house i can
buy it
or i can get a loan and take over the
loan that way
but they just don't and they rent from
me he doesn't want to do that he doesn't
want to rent
i'm saying well you can live under the
bridge then if that's the case
what is your suggestion here should i
just let them live under the bridge or
should i
and right now as an added they have got
a
mortgage specialist paying a hundred
dollars a month for his
stupid advice that i've already given
them and that they could do by
themselves
so what is your suggestion if his wife
is unwilling to join in finances and
sign to keep her own home
under her then she is losing the house
not you
yes agree is unwilling that he is
unwilling to rent the house back
he is losing the house not you mm-hmm
i'll buy the house but she does not live
here she is out is what i said she does
not rent from me
she is out if she's not willing to uh
put her name on your loan she is out of
the house what i said and they're close
to that anyway so it's no big loss
well larry i'd be careful about getting
in between your son and his wife
well true i agree and that that may cost
you down the road if they end up
reconciling and you've you've put a
thorn in something sometimes you say
some things
relationally you can't ever get back
yeah i i agree with that
i i just would i would wash my hands of
it and just stand back say i love you
guys if you need some help with food or
something i'll help you later but i
can't help you with the house because
all the stuff you're doing is not
anything that i can do
and i'm sorry yeah i i would
let natural consequences take there's
too much going on here that you can't
fix
and they're unwilling to address and so
those are those are two reasons you've
got to let this go it's very painful to
watch people you love be stupid though
um happens to all of us this is the dave
ramsey show